[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مع مشاهدين الكرام نواصل واياكم
هذه التغطيه الانتخابات التجديد النصفيه
للكونغرس في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الان ولايه ايلي نوي تعلن تعرضها لهجوم
الكتروني سيؤثر على اليه التصويت في
انتخابات التجديد النصفي سنبقي عينا على
مثل هذه الاخبار ولكن البدايه مع الاخبار
عن مواصلات الامريكيين اليوم التصويت
بكثافه لكن متى يمكننا معرفه اي حزب باتت
بيده الاغلبيه فعلا بعد اذلاء الناخبين
باصواتهم اليوم قد يستغرق انتظار نتائج
ليله طويله وربما اياما قبل ان يقتضح ما
اذا كان الجمهوريون او الديمقراطيون هم
فازوا وسيطر على الكونجرس يتوقع كثيرون
موجه ضخمه من الدعم للحزب الجمهوري وضغطا
كبيرا من الرئيس السابق ترامب وهو ما يمكن
ان يؤدي الى اعلان الجمهوريين النصر بعد
ساعات من اغلاق صناديق الاقتراع لكن عده
ولايات رئيسيه مثل بنسلفينيا سبقت هذا
الامر بالاعلان عن ان فرز كل بطاقات
الاقتراع قد يستغرق اياما هناك مساله اخرى
وهي التصويت عبر البريد بعض الولايات تفرز
اصوات البريد مبكرا قبل يوم الانتخابات ما
قد يرجح كافه حزب على اخر بينما ولايات
اخرى لا تبدا بفرز هذه الاصوات الا في يوم
الانتخابات لذا قد تستغرق العمليه عده
ايام في هذه الولايه
[موسيقى]
هذا و غرد الرئيس الامريكي جومايدن اكثر
من مره اليوم داعيا انصاره الديمقراطيين
للاقتراع في انتخابات التجديد النصفي
مشددا على ان الديمقراطيين قادرون على صنع
التغيير في انتخابات الكونغرس
بدوره ادلى الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب بصوته في فلوريدا مشددا على ضروره
التصويت لان الولايات المتحده فقدت
مكانتها على حد قوله وجدد ترامب التاكيد
على ان الثلاثاء المقبل سيحمل اخبارا
مثيره ولكن دون التصريح بعزمه الترشح
للانتخابات المقبله
[موسيقى]
ولكن الاهم ان تصوتوا انها انتخابات مهمه
جدا واتمنى ان يحدث الصواب اعتقد ان اول
شيء يجب التركيز عليه هو الجريمه هو تخفيض
الضرائب لدينا اكبر ضرائب في التاريخ
وسيواصل الديمقراطيون رفعها ويجب اغلاق
الحدود ولذلك اعتقد انه من المهم مواصله
اغلاق الحدود وتخفيض الضرائب اعتقد ان
الثلاثاء المقبل سيحمل اخبار مثيرا واتطلع
لرؤيتكم في ماريلا
ملفات عده ينقسم حولها الامريكيون في
انتخابات التجديد النصفي للكونجرس انقسام
صارخ في الواقع ينعكس على صناديق الاقتراع
استطلاع لصحيفه واشنطن بوستو واي بي سي
نيوز وجد ان الناخبين يرون ان الحسبه
الجمهوري يجيد حل بعض القضايا الشائكه
ويتقدم في الاقتصاد وفي حجم الاقبال
الناخبين بحسب الاستطلاع تنقسم نوايا
الناخبين باقتراع مجلس النواب بالتساوي
بين الحزبين
49% من الناخبين المسجلين قالوا انهم
سيصوطون للمرشح الجمهوري بينما قال 88% من
الناخبين المسجلين انهم سيصوتون للحزب
الديمقراطي اما الناخبون المحتملون
تنقسموا الى 50 بالمئه يملون نحو التصويت
للجمهوريين وثمانيه واربعين بالمئه يملون
نحو التصويت للديمقراطيين ومع الانتخابات
الحاليه دحوم توقعات بخساره الحزب الحاكم
للاغلبيه فكما هو معتز لا يصل الحزب
المسيطر على كرسي الرئاسه للاغلبيه في
الكونغرس فيما يحتاج الجمهوريون الى سته
مقاعد للوصول الى الاغلبيه يواجه
الديمقراطيون تحديا في محاوله قلب
المعادله ووقف مكاسب منافسهم الجمهوري لا
يمكن الاستطلاعات الراي ان تحدد بشكل دقيق
المقاعد التي قد يخسرها او يربحها اي من
الحزبين لكن نوايا الناخبين اوضح من
الارقام والتوقعات الناخب جمهوري لا يزال
واثقا من نيته التصويت لصالح حزبه بنحو
80% بينما يبقى الناخب الديمقراطي متخبيطا
بنحو اربعه 74% وهو اقل بثمان نقاط عن ما
كان عليه عام 2018
فسوه اخرى اوسع في المنافسه بين الحزبين
فالناخب الجمهوري مهتم بمتابعه مجريات
الانتخابات عن كتب بنحو 48 بالمئه مقارنه
ب 37 بالمئه للديمقراطيه التشتت الكبير في
اراء الشارع حول قضايا ملحها للجميع انعكس
ايضا على استطلاع اخر اجرته شبكته ام بي
سي نيوز اشار الى ان 90 بالمئه من
الناخبين يفضلون سيطره الجمهوريين على
الكونجرس لضبط ملف الهجره مع 65% يفضلونهم
في ملف الجريمه و60 بالمئه يريدونهم
لتحسين الاقتصاد والوظائف في المقابل هناك
86% يفضلون سيطره الديمقراطيين لملف
المناخ مع 74% لملف الاسلحه كما اختارهم
67% لمواجهه تهديدات الديمقراطيه
[موسيقى]
انت معك رصيد
ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
سر
معك
[موسيقى]
وائل المزيد من التفاصيل الميدانيه حول
هذا اليوم الانتخابي الطويل في الولايات
المتحده معنا مراسله العربيه ريتا سليمان
من ولايه نيفادا تحديدا اهلا بك ريتا
ولايه نيفادا ولايه من الولايات الحاسمه
في هذه الانتخابات كما عديد الولايات
الاخرى مثل بنسلفانيا وسكانسن وجورجيا
ونيهانشر وهايو ما الذي يميز هذا اليوم
كما تراقبينه عن كتب والناخبون يبدون خلفك
في هذه الصوره
صحيح انا في مركز
انتخابي في جنوب لاس فيغاس مدينه
الواقعه في مقاطعه كلارك كلارك كانتي في
هذا المركز تبعنا افتتاحه
وبدايه تدفق الناخبين للانتلاقي باصواتهم
لاحظنا طاهر منذ ساعات صباح الاولى قبل
افتتاح هذا المركز بساعه كان ال اا
الناخبون متواجدين في همم خارجه همم يقفون
في الطوابير لاذلاء باصواتهم قبل الذهاب
الى عمله همم
في الصباح في الصباح كانت كانت مستوياتها
اعلى مرتفعه لانه العالم ارادوا ان
ينتخبوا قبل الذهاب الى عملهم هذا ليس يوم
فرصه في نيفادا بحسب قوانين الولايات ولكن
اقبال ظل بنسبه عاليه ليس بوتيره الصباح
ولكنه ظل بنسبه متساويه حتى اللحظه
العاملون هنا يتوقعون زياده بنسبه الاقبال
على الاقتراع مع انتهاء يوم العمل وساعات
العمل حوالي الساعه الرابعه الرابعه ونصف
يتوقعون تدفق ان الناخبين بنسب اكبر
ولكنهم راضون على نسبه الاقبال حتى اللحظه
في داخل هذا المركز همم تبعنا تبعنا كل
التفاصيل تعرفنا على تفاصيل هذا الاقتراع
كيف يتم نعم عظيم جدا من خلال هذه
التفاصيل التي تابعتيها من خلال احاديث
[موسيقى]
على افكار او على قضايا تهم جيوبهم
بالدرجه الاولى وهل هم معنيون بقضايا
دوليه وعالميه كما نبثها في الاخبار
باوكرانيا مثلا او بالعالم العربي او غير
محترفين بذلك
تهمه بتاتا واطلاقا سياسه الخارجيه ما
يهمه هو همم الاقتصاد في نيفادا تحديدا
وكاون نيفادا هي الاكثر تاثرا في الولايات
المتحده
اقتصاديا خلال السنوات الاخيره بدءا من
رائحه كورونا والاغلاق الذي حصل كان
نيفادا معروفه
بقطاع السياحي فنادق والكازينوهات
والمطاعم كلها اغلق طيله فتره الاطلاق
حوالي سنه بعد الاغلاق اتى تضخم ليقضي على
اي امل باصلاح الوضع الاقتصادي بالتالي
اهالي نيفادا مهتمون فقط بوضع الاقتصادي
والارتفاع ايضا اسعار الوقود تحدثنا الى
المواطنين وسالناهم عن خياراتهم الاقتصاد
ثم الاقتصاد والاقتصاد هو العنوان الوحيد
ولكن طاهر في هذه العمليه في
الناخب يدخل من هذا الباب يجلس هنا تحديدا
عند هذه النقطه يتم التاكد منه هويته يعطى
بطاقه ياخذها بعد
يتم التاكد من هويته لي خلف هذه الصناديق
وهذا وهذه العوازل تحديدا ما يجري البطاقه
التي ياخذها من هنا يضعها في الحاسوب من
بعد الحاسوب تظهر امامه على الشاشه عده
همم نقاط
سيقترح عليها اليا طبعا من بين النقاب
مقاعد السيناتور مقاعد الحكام الولايات
مقاعد النواب القضاه المدعون العمود وايضا
من ضمن ما يقترح عليه ان ياخذ في النفاثه
ده هي همم سياسه المقاطعه بمعنى انه في
هذا في هذه الشاشه تحديدا هناك خيارات
عليها ان يتخذها من بين القضايا دي
سيحسمها انها همم هي مساله اذا ما كان
يريد الناخب اا فيما بعد التدخل في اختيار
الشخصيات للاحزاب المنافسه له ولكن ما
ابرز عوامل القوه والضاعف
كلا الحزبين وعند كل المرشحين من الحزبين
كاملين مجلس الشيوخ او مجلس النواب او
للحكام همم ما الذي يمكن ان نقول انه
سيكون العامل الحاسم اكثر لجهه نقاط القوه
والضعف هذا
في ما خص
الديمقراطيين ومجلس الشيوخ
رسائل الحزب الديمقراطي ليست جاذبه للناخب
في نيفادا ان كان من جهه قضيه الاجهاض
بالنسبه
لاهالي نيفادا هو مضمون دستوريا في قوانين
الولايه وليس من خطر عليه بان يتم الغاءه
بالتالي خسر الديمقراطيين هذه النقطه يبقى
العامل الاقتصادي الذي جاء معاكسا تماما
لتطلعات همم الديمقراطيين هناك انتقادات
كبيره همم لهم همم للقضايا وهمم وفي كيف
تعاملوا مع قضيه الاقتصاد وايضا ارتفاع
همم الوقود على الوقود ليقضي على كل
امالهم في تحسين الاقتصاد همم
يطالبون بتحسين مستوى الدراسه لهم همم
لاولادهم يطالبون ايضا بتوفير العمل همم
قضيه الهجره ليست ايضا جاذبه بالنسبه
لاهالي نيفادا تحدثنا مع مهاجرين لاتينيين
همم الذين يشكلون حوالي 30% من الخريطه
ديموغرافيه لنيفادا هم ليسوا مهتمين
بالهجرهم فقط يهمهم الهجره النظاميه
وبالتالي وعود الديمقراطيين ليست جاذبه
لهم يريدون فقط تامين همم الطعام لعائلتهم
همم
باخر النهار يعني تماما شكرا جزيلا اريد
تسليما العربيه الى ولايه بعد لتغطيه هذه
الانتخابات يعطيك الف عافيه يوم طويل
امامك وامام جميع مراسلين على الارض
ونتابع واياكم من ولايه اخرى حاسمه ايضا
جورجيا الانتخابات في جورجيا هذا العام
لها خصوصيه شديده فكما نرى او سنرى قد
تحسم الولايه الاغلبيه لاحد الحزبين في
مجلس الشيوخ بين الشحات الجمهوري هيرشي
الوكر والديمقراطي رافاييل وورد ايضا
الولايه او للولايه ذاتها تاثير كبير على
نتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه
فالفائز بها يحصل على 16 صوتا في المجمع
الانتخابي هذه خريطه نتائج انتخابات في
ولايات الجنوب الشرقيه عام 2016 بين
هيلاري كلينتون ودونالد ترامب كما نرى
ذهبت جميعها الى المرشح الجمهوريه
وهذه الخريطه ايضا تظهر نتائج الولايه في
انتخابات عام 2020 بين جو بادن كل هذه
الولايات ذهبت لترامب ما عدد جورجيا وهو
الامر الذي لم يعني يصدقه ترامب بل دعاهه
بعد ذلك للزعم بوجود تزوير في تلك النتائج
من ابرز العوامل التي تسببت في هذه
النتيجه
تحدي مقاتيه لمنصب حاكم جورجيا في سباق
الانتخابات الحاليه ستايسي ابرامز خاضت
السباق على منصب حاكم جورجيا امام براين
كامب في عام 2018 وخسرت نفس السباق يتكرر
بين الاثنين هذه الانتخابات حينما خسرت
ستايسي عملت على تسجيل الناخبين من ذوي
الاصول الافريقيه في كشوف الانتخابات
ليكون قوه دفعا للديمقراطيين وبالفعل نجحت
في تسجيل 800,000 ناخبا جديد يعتقد ان هذه
الاصوات التي سجلتها هي ما تسببت في فوزي
جو بيضا بولايه جورجيا في الانتخابات عام
[موسيقى]
في هذه الانتخابات كما اسلفنا تتنافس
مجددا استيسي ابرونز اذا على منصب الحاكم
مع الجمهوري برايم كم سباق لا يهتم به
ترامب كثيرا في الواقع فهو يريد ان يخسر
الاثنان لو كان ذلك ممكنا فابرايم كانت
الحاكم الجمهوري الحالي رفض الاسخاء
لترامب خلال الانتخابات 2020 حينما طلب
منه وقف اعتماد تصويت جورجيا تظهر
استطلاعات الراي ان كان سيحصل على ولايه
جديده في جورجيا رغم كل جهود السيسي
ابرامز في هذا المجال في جورجيا ايضا يوجد
سباق على منصب سكرتير الولايه وهو المنصب
المسؤول مباشره على الاشراف على
الانتخابات الرئاسيه يسال جمهوريه
الى ولايه جديده هذا الرجل ايضا يكرهه
ترامب كثيرا فاروق
الاقوياء الا ان كل شيء تغير مع انتخابات
عام 2020 حينما طلب منه ترامب ايضا ان
يفتش على اكثر من 11,000 صوت لصالحه لقلب
النتيجه امام بيدن
رفض طلب ترامب وتمسك بموقفه وشاهد ضده
ايضا في تحقيقات الكونجرس بشان اقتحام
الكابتل في السادس من يناير وتم نشر تسريب
للمحادثه الهاتفيه بينه وبين ترامب
او ميسي
[موسيقى]
والله بنت يا اوشن
اذا مقرر الامريكيون منح مجلس الشيوخ
والنواب الى الجمهوريين وبالتالي نتوقف مع
هذه الصور لتصويت نائبه الرئيس الامريكي
تقوم بالتصويت ويمكن ان نرى على امل ان
نرى الصور والفيديوهات ثابته بعد قليل
نتمنى ذلك لكي نراها وهي تصوت اذا كانت
تدخل او كانت التصويت اصلا واضح طبعا عدد
كبير من المرافقين معها وهي تقوم بهذا
التصويت حاليا اذا يمكن ان نتحدث عن عدد
كبير في هذا اليوم من المسؤولين المهمين
الذين يبدون باصواتهم في الانتخابات
النصفيه الحاسمه في الكثير من الولايات
المحسومه في بعض الولايات والحاسمه في
ولايات اخرى اذا نحن نتحدث عن استمرار
لهذا اليوم الانتخابي الطويل الذي تحتدم
فيه السباقات في مسلسل
جورجيا ونيوهانشر واوهايو ويمكن لاي من
هذه الولايات ان تغير في موازين القوى اذا
نحن بانتظار ان نرى كمال حارس ربما بعد
قليل
اذا قد يخرج الرئيس الامريكي من هذه
الانتخابات خاسرا كل شيء اذا ما قرر
الامريكيون من حمل لسي شيوخ ونواب الى
الجمهوريين وبالتالي سيحاولون الباقي من
رئاسته الى جنود ازميل سوهاج شرايير
يسحبنا في تفاصيل هذا الجانب من
الانتخابات النصفيه المتابعه
[موسيقى]
ما يجب ان نعرفه عن الانتخابات النصفيه في
امريكا كما تعلمون انتخابات الرئاسه
الامريكيه تجرى كل اربع سنوات وهذا
الاختيار رئيس للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الانتخابات النصفيه هي تجرى كل سنتين
وسميت نصفيه لانها تاتي في منتصفه ولايه
الرئيس
لماذا هي مهمه الانتخابات النصفيه ولانها
في منتصف ولايه الرئيس فهي بمثابه استفتاء
حقيقي على مدى رضا الامريكيين عن اداء
رئيسهم واذا كانوا يرغبون في تعطيل
قراراته بانتخاب اغلبيه في الكونجرس من
الحزب الاخر
يتعلق الامر كله بمن يسيطر على هذا المبنى
الكونجرس يعود الامر الى عام
1787 عندما قرر واضع الدستور الامريكي ان
البرلمان سيتكون من غرفتين وهذا ما حصلوا
عليه
الكونجرس يتكون من غرفتين مجلس النواب ب
435 مقعدا وتبقا للماده الاولى من الدستور
الامريكي ينتخب اعضائه مجلس النواب كل
سنتين اما مجلس الشيوخ الذي يضم 100 مقعد
ينتخب الشيوخ فيه كل ست سنوات
[موسيقى]
السباق في الانتخابات النصفيه بين الحزبين
الديمقراطي والجمهوري يكونوا على
435 مقعدا في مجلس النواب اي كامل المجلس
وخمسه وثلاثين مقعدا من مجلس الشيوخ اي
ثلث اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ الذي يضم 100 مقعد
كذلك ينتخب الامريكيون في هذا الثامن من
نوفمبر اعضاء المجالس المحليه وحكام 36
ولايه من اصل 50 ولايه امريكيه
الوضع الحالي الديمقراطيون لديهم اغلبيه
ضئيله في مجلس النواب منذ عام
1934 فاز حزب الرئيس باغلبيه مجلس النواب
في الانتخابات النصفيه ثلاث مرات فقط اما
مجلس الشيوخ فهو منقسم بخمسين مقعدا لكل
الحزبين وسيجري التنافس على 34 مقعدا منها
في هذه الانتخابات النصفيه
منذ العام
1934 فاز حزب الرئيس 6 مرات باغلبيه مجلس
الشيوخ وفي مره واحده فقط لم يحصل تغير
للاغلبيه في المسجد
شكرا على هذا العرض المميز وانواصل في
تغطيات على الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه
ولكن بعد الفاصل فارجو ان تبقى معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في لقاء مع العربيه
ما قد يخيمان على العامين المقبلين لفتره
رئاسه
دقيقه دقيقه
الاستاذ
[موسيقى]
وعلى وقع هذه الاخبار العاجله التي نتبعها
نقل العنفذ العربيه عن اطلاق سفارات
الانذار في العاصمه كيف نتابع في تغطياتنا
للانتخابات النصفيه
فتتقيد القرارات العسكريه للرئيس الامريكي
الى حد كبير في حاله خساره حزمه الاغلبيه
في غرفتي الكونجرس الشيوخ والنواب فبماذا
يخبرون التاريخ عن علاقه الحروب التي كانت
الولايات المتحده طرفا فيها او دائما لاحد
الخصوم فيها والانتخابات التشريعيه
[موسيقى]
الانتخابات التجديد النصفي تتزامل مع
الحرب في اوكرانيا التي قوضت اقتصاد
العالم
الماضي في الولايات المتحده تزامل بعضها
مع حروب او نزاعات عسكريه شاركت فيها
امريكا بشكل مباشر او غير مباشر على
نتائجها
في الاثني عشر جوله من جولات التجديد
النصفي التي خسرها حزب الرئيس الامريكي ان
عقدت ثمان جولات منها تزامنا او عقب حروب
تاثر بها الشان الامريكي
الحربان العالميتان القطا بظلالهما
القادمه على الاقتصاد الامريكي وكانت
المحصله خساره الحزب الديمقراطي اغلبيه
مجلس اي شيوخ النواب في استحقاقي تجديد
النصفي عمي
1918 و 294
اما الحزب الجمهوري فاخسر اغلبيه الغرفتين
اثناء سيطرته على الرئاسه الامريكيه عام
1986 و 20990 وهي الانتخابات التي جرت
بالتزامن مع الحرب السوفيتي على
الافغانستان والحرب العراقيه الايرانيه
صحيح انها تين الحربين لم تتدخل فيهما
واشنطن بشكل مباشر الا ان دعمها لاحد
طرفيها لم يتوقف ابدا فتره حكم بوشنكم
[موسيقى]
اما العام 2002 فكان الوضع استثنائيا خلال
المده الاولى لبوش الابن وفي اعقاب هجمات
ال 11 من سبتمبر تجمع الامريكيون خلفه حزب
الرئيس وفاز الجمهوريون باغلبيه بسيطه
بلغت ثمانيه مقاعد في مجلس النواب لكن
لاحقا على جورج بوش الابن نفس معاناه ابيه
ففي اول انتخابات عقبه حربي العراق
وافغانستان خاسره حزبه الجمهوري اغلبيه
الكونجرس بغرفتي في انتخابات عام 2006
المراه القويه وجه الديمقراطيين اللامع
لعقدين من الزمن نانسي بيلوسي
على مهمتها في الخدمه العامه مع مستقبل
سياسي غير واضح وانتخابات تهدد اغلبيه
الديمقراطيين في مجلس النواب والاعتداء
الاخير على زوجها كل ذلك اثقل كاهله اول
امراه تتبوا هذا المنصب الرفيع اعتبرها
العديد من الخبراء اقوى رؤساء مجلس النواب
منذ اكثر من 100 عام تراست الديمقراطيين
الذين خسروا الاغلبيه في عام 2010 ثم بقيت
بتحدن على راس المؤتمر الحزبي وقادتهم الى
السلطه مجددا في 2000 2018 عندما استعادت
مطرقه القياده جاءت بوعد غامض بالتنحي
نهايه 20 22
ليتهافت الطامحون على خلافتها للحصول على
دعمها راى متابعون ان بي لو ربما اتخذت
قرارها منذ اشهر مشيرين الى زيارتها الى
تايوان في مواجهه انتقادات حاده من بكين
وما يشبه اللون من وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه نوع الرحله هذه يقوم بها من
يعلم ان مغادرته للمسرح اصبحت وشيكا وسواء
كانت النتيجه فوزا او خساره للاغلبيه
البقاء او المغادره العام المقبل لا شك ان
نانسي فيلوسي تركت بالفعل بصمه تاريخيه في
مجلس النواب والكونغرس عموما بل والامه
الامريكيه ككل بحسب ما تقول واشنطن بوست
عنها
وهو جمهوريه اصطدم معه لوسي في التسعينات
عندما كان رئيسا لمجلس النواب في مقابله
له العام الماضي يمكنك المجادله بانها
كانت اقوى رئيسه للمجلس في التاريخ
بعد تسلها رئاسه مجلس النواب للمره الاولى
عام 2007 كانت بلوسيا النجمه الديمقراطيه
اللامعه مع نصر حزبها وسيطرته على
الغالبيه لتتحول بعدها وتحديدا عام 2010
الى وجه الهزيمه عقب خساره الديمقراطيين
لكنها لم تياس وظلت تقاتل لاستعاده
الاغلبيه هذه هي
الديمقراطيه وهو ما تحقق عام 2018
ولتقف حجره حجره عتره ثقيلا امام الرئيس
الجمهوريه السابق دونالد ترامب حتى تولد
السلطه اليوم ومره اخرى فان الديمقراطيين
بقياده بيلقصي على وشك الخساره وفق
استطلاعات الراي لذلك ربما اصبح لزاما
عليها ان تسلم الرايه لجيل اخر لكن
بالتاكيد لن يكون البديل روسيا انجاز
التعبير فهي كما يقول هنا اخذت السلطه ولم
تطلبها
عديد الملفات والعناوين الساخنه في هذه
الانتخابات النصفيه الذي التي يعني تعتبر
من الاهم في تاريخ الانتخابات النصفيه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومن اصدر
واقدر من ناديه البلبيسي مراسله العربيه
من واشنطن لتحاور في هذا الموضوع مع
ضيفيها في الاستديو في واشنطن فاليك ناديه
شكرا لك والكلمه لكي
شكرا لك يا طاهر اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
في هذه التغطيه المستمره على شاشه العربيه
طبعا تحدثنا عن الكثير من الملفات اسهبنا
في ملفات السياسه الخارجيه لكن اريد ان
اتحدث عن نقطه ذكرتها بالتحديد طهرها
وموضوع الديمقراطيه طبعا نعود مره اخرى مع
الاستاذ احمد الحنطي ومع الاستاذ حسين عبد
الحسين الرئيس
مرتين تحدث عن الديمقراطيه وكانت شعار
عريض بان الديمقراطيه في خطر هل يستطيع ان
يقول او يخون اتباع ترامب ما يسميهم
بالماجا الذي وصفهم بانهم شبه فاشين وشبه
نازيين والى اخره همم بانهم خطر على
الديمقراطيه هل الولايات المتحده الان على
مفترق طرق نستطيع ان نقول بان الديمقراطيه
نفسها في خطر يعني ممكن ليس في 22 يمكن في
24 اكثر في الانتخابات الرئاسيه اكثر همم
في 22 السنه هذه في كثير من المرشحين
للكونجرس واللي بعض الانتخابات المحليه
يعني من رفض نتيجه الانتخابات 2020 وهذا
قد يمثل الخطوه الاولى ولكن الخطوه
الرئيسيه انه ياتي رئيس سواء كان ترامب او
غيره ويرفض نتيجه الرئاسه ويتمكن من يعني
من نقض نتيجه الانتخابات هنا ستكون يعني
الديمقراطيه في امريكا
يعني صدق صناديق الاقتراع والمرشحين نفسهم
لكن في اهم الديمقراطيات في العالم كله
نتحدث عن ديمقراطيه عريقه همم خاضت حروب
حروب الاستقلال او حرب الاستقلال حتى تؤسس
في هذه الجمهوريه مؤسسين اوائل مثل جورج
واشنطن
وغيرهم الان نتحدث على انه بالفعل الرئيس
قبل قليل على فكره قبل ان يكون على الهواء
كان يقول مره اخرى اذهبوا الى صناديق
الاقتراع لانه الديمقراطيه هي من احد اهم
القضايا هل يبالغ الرئيس ترامب عفوا
بايديا في ذلك
انا كمواطن امريكي طبعا اخاف على هذه
الديمقراطيه وطبعا لا يخيفني الراي يعني
اذا كان فاشي او اذا كان عنصري ابيض هذا
مقبول ما يخيفني هو انتشار ثقافه عدم قبول
النتائج وعدم قبول لنتائج ليس الانتخابات
العامه فحسب انما داخل الحزب الجمهوري
يعني هناك جمهوريون خاسر وداخل حزب
الجمهوري الانتخابات التمهيديه ولم يقبل
النتيجه امام جمهوريين يعني منافسين فهذه
الثقافه اعتقد انها طبعا تشكل خطر على كما
تفضلته واحده من اعرق الديمقراطيات في
العالم وتاليا على كل الديمقراطيات يعني
اذا امريكا تراجعت في هذا الموضوع اعتقد
الموضوع سينسحب على باقي الدنيا
يعني اعتقد انه الرئيس السابق ترامب بشجع
هذه النزعه لا شك انها هي كانت موجوده
ولكنها كانت على الهامش اليوم صارت يعني
جزء من الحياه اليوميه يعني لطالما كان
الامريكيون من الطرفين يعني الديمقراطين
يشاركون بانتخابات ترامب يشككون بانتخاب
جورج بوش الابن ولكن كانت على الهامش مع
ترامب هذه صارت في صلب العمليه الانتخابيه
الديمقراطيه واعتقد هذا خطر هذا خطر يخيف
الامريكيين طبعا يخيف الرئيس
وعدد كبير حتى من الجمهوريين انفسهم
الانتخابات عام 2000 كنا نذكر انه قدم
قراتيه كانت متوقفه على مئات من الاصوات
يعني ما بين جورج بوش وما بين جورج كان
320 سنت او ما شبه تسوون لو كانت هذه
النتائج الان نتحدث عنها من كان سيقبل
بهذه النتائج يعني قال جول اتصل بالرئيس
بوش وهنؤه في ذلك الوقت فهذا الموضوع
بالفعل يعني لن ينتهي في هذه الانتخابات
وكما قلت ربما سنراه اكثر بشكل معمق في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لكن همم اريد ان
اربطها بموضوع التصويت هناك 48 اعتقد
مليون امريكي صوتوا حتى الان في التصويت
المبكر وهذا جزء منه البعض يرى بانه
الجمهوريين يشكك فيه لانه لا يؤمنون
بتصويت عبر البريد بينما ال- ال-
الجمهوريين يريدون ان يكونوا موجودين في
صناديق الاقتراع اليوم هل تاخر
الديمقراطيه من وجهه نظرك استاذ احمد همم
في همم ربما الحديث عن الاقتصاد يعني
الديمقراطيه هو موضوع مهم لكن بالنهايه
اذا لم يكن في جيب المواطن الامريكي ما
يكفي لدفع فواتير الكهرباء والماء والغاز
والى غيره هو سيصوت للحزب الذي على الاقل
يحمل هذا الشعر سيوفر له هذا
الديمقراطيين فشلوا في تسويق رسالاتهم
الاقتصاديه يعني الحقيقه ان اداره
تحققت انجازات لا باس بها على مستوى
الاقتصاد
نسبه البطاله المنخفضه جدا النمو لا باس
به التضخم عالي ولكن التضخم ظاهره عالميه
وليست ظاهره امريكيه ولكن الديمقراطيين
كعادتهم
فشل تماما في توصيل الرساله في كيفيه
التعامل مع ان اخفق مع الناخب بانه ما
تراه ما تعاني منه اليوم هو الثمن عدم
بقاله في المنزل البطاله منخفضه لان
التضخم عالي وليس العكس
بالفعل بان الديمقراطيين يبتعدون عن او
يخجلنا من الحديث عن قضايا مهمه بالنسبه
للناخر مثل موضوع الاقتصاد مثل التضخم مثل
الجريمه العاليه يعني لماذا لا يتحدثون
عنها ايضا انه بالنهايه نرى الجمهوريه
يحملون شعار الوطنيه يحملون الاعلام
الامريكيه بينما الديمقراطيه كانهم يخجلون
من كونهم امريكيين بالدرجه الاولى طبعا لا
اعتقد انه هي فقط المشكله في الرساله بدات
ديمقراطيين اعتقد انه في المشكله في
الخيارات اعتقد انه رئيس بلد اخطا بتركه
الموضوع الاقتصادي لاقصى اليسار بقياده
بنيسندرز همم يعني الاموال التي انفقها
الكونجرس بعد دخول بيدن اعتقد انها ادت
الى حد كبير في رفع مستوى التضخم وكذلك
الامر في موضوع الجريمه يعني نحن نعرف انه
يسار الوسط الامريكي هو مع الشرطه ولكن
اقصى اليسار يعني يرفض تمويل الشرطه وهذا
ما ادى الى رفع الجريمه فا اعتقل ان هناك
خطوات قام بها اقصى اليسار قادى بها الحزب
الديمقراطي وادت الى هذه المشاكل والان
يعني الحزب الديمقراطي الموضوع ليس رساله
فحس ولكن ان هو كان سيعارض فهذا يعني
المواجهه داخل حزب الديمقراطيسه لانه يعني
سيذهب الى مواجهه
ساندرس يوم التقدمين مقابل ما يسمى
بالوسطين
سيذهب الى مواجهه معهم ولذلك اعتقد انه
حاول ديموقراطيون ان يجعلوا هذه
الانتخابات حول شخص ترامب وترامب نجح في
البقاء ساكته ههه قد يكلف هذه الانتخابات
هو المرشحين نفسهم يعني اختيار المرشحين
كنا نقول بان ربما ترامب كان يدعم مرشحين
غير مؤهلين مثل مامه اوز الي هو طبيب كان
لديه برنامج على التلفزيون وكان يسكن في
نيويورك قرر الانتقال الى بن سيلفينا
بنسلفانيا هذه الولايه على حسب لكن ايضا
مرشح الديمقراطيين يعني ليس عظيما
وبالنهايه الحسبان يدفعني الثمن في اختيار
المرشحين صح يعني انا اعتقد انه فطر الفوز
لو ما جاءته الجلطه الجلطه هي اللي غيرته
يعني بنسلفانيا تماما قبل كان متقدم كثير
منها
في المخ قبل اشهر بسيطه يعني اتمنى
الانتخابات
هذه كلها اضعفت حبوب كثيره لو لم يصب
بالجلطه لا فاز على الاقل ثلاث نقاط
بالتاكيد طيب هل يلام اي من الحسبين على
رفع بعض الشعارات الان اا وبات الوقت
الوقت متاخر تماما في اقناع اي ناخب ونحن
نتحدث عن 48 مليون صوتوا يعني مش مهم ماذا
يقول الرئيس الليله وماذا يقول الرئيس همم
ترامب او حتى رئيس اوباما او نجوم كل من
الحسبين انه نخب الامريكي تقريبا ثلث
المؤهلين التصويت صوته
ولكن اعتقد انه الولايات المتارجه قليله
ويعني هامش الاصوات للفوز عاده ضيق
واعتقد انه كلنا الحزبان يعتقد انه حتى
اخر صوت يدخل الى صندوقه الاقتراع مهم
بالنسبه
الى فارق بين الاثنين فلذلك يعني
نرى اندفاع من الحزبين حتى اخر دقيقه
وربما حتى بعد ذلك اعتقد انه يعني انت اخر
فرز النتائج نتوقع ان تكون هناك مواجهه
سياسيه اكبر من مواجهه الحملاتين
الانتخابيتين الحاصل حتى الان
الديمقراطين كانوا يعتقدون بانها الورقه
الرابحه وهو موضوع الاجهاض اللي هو طبعا
المحكمه العليا قامت بقلب هذا القانون
الذي سمحت
كحمايه فيدراليه للولايات ان لا يعني ان
يكون هناك السماح بحريه الاجهاض لكن الان
هذا الموضوع كان متفاعل في الصيف الان لم
يعد على هذه القائمه الاولويات قبل قليل
كنت استمع الى بعض الاراء كانوا يقولون
باننا لا نصوت على موضوع الارشاد فقط هناك
قضايا كثيره جدا هل يعني بالنهايه الذاكره
همم اذا اردت بالنسبه لمناخب الامريكي
قصيره بمعنى بانها مرتبطه بفتره زمنيه
محدوده جدا يمكن ان تحدد هذه الانتخابات
لا اعتقد ان موضوع يعني قصه الذاكره
بالدرجه الاولى اعتقد انه بالدرجه الاولى
انه في الولايات الزرقاء
حق الاجهاض محمي فبالتالي هم ليسوا بحاجه
لحمايه وليسوا بحاجه للتصويت على اساسها
لما تكون رساله الحزب مركزه على هذا الامر
يعني يظل غير مقنع للناخذ في الولايات
الحمراء شاهدنا ارتفاع في معدل
الديمقراطيين نتيجه لموضوع الاجهاض لانه
يعني من يريدون حمايه حق الاجهاض
بداوا بالخروج بالتصويت بشكل اكبر لصالح
الديمقراطيين حتى لو خرج في مقابله او في
استطلاع رايه وقال اهم شيء الاقتصاد رجل
صندوق الاقتراع بالدرجه الاولى
الكثير من القضايا التي يمكن ان نتحدث
عنها لكن انتهى وقتنا هنا شكرا لك يا
استاذ احمد
اليك مره اخرى طاهر في فيديوهاتنا فيديو
دبي
جوجل
اغراض مختلفه وليس هناك اي ادله لم اقترح
بذلك
من يود ان يطرح سؤال اخر
اذا ما اعلن دونالد ترامب ماذا ستفعلين
ردت فعله سيكون سعيده للغايه وبتاكيد سوف
ادعمه
بكل ما اوتيته من قوه اريد من دونك يصلحه
ما اسده
اذا ما فزتي في هذه الانتخابات وحصلت على
منصب حاكم مارينا هل تسمعينها تمضيه
الولايه بكاملها او انك تترشحين لمنصب اخر
لقد جبت عليه السؤال وقلت انني ساكون
حاكمه اريزونا
لاربع سنوات اوروبا مرساه اضلوا في هذا
المنصب لثمانيه سنوات وسوف يحدث
شرطه بوت شرطه
فروت اذن هناك رابط يمكن لكم ان تلجا اليه
للتصويت اذا
اترك الامر للحاكم ليعقد الامر اكثر اذا
الاكشن
شرطه شرطه
على تويتر
عندما يفوز بمنصب الحاكم سوف يصحح كل هذه
الاخطاء هل من اسئله اخرى
اذا مشاهدينا الكرام استمعنا الى كلمه
كاري ليك وهي المرشحه لمنصب الحاكم في
اريزونا كانت اعلنت عن ترشحها في الاول من
يونيو من عام 20 21 يدعمها ترامب بشده وهي
مذيعه تلفزيونيه سابقه تنقلت بين
الديمقراطين والجمهوريين والاستقلاليه في
انتماءاتها الحزبيه خطابات عده في تاريخ
الكونجرس الامريكي تتعاظم مع تقادم الزمن
حيث رسمت مسارات حروب
ابرزها خطاب الرئيس فرانكلين روزفلت الذي
وصف بيوم العار واعلن خلاله حاله الحرب
على اليابان
عده وقفت على هذه المنصه تبعت محطات زمنيه
واحدث التغييرا جذريا بسير الازمات رؤساء
امريكيون اعتلوا منبر الكونغرس وادلب
خطابات حفرت في الذاكره احدها ادخل
الولايات المتحده الحرب العالميه الثانيه
من ديسمبر
1941 طلب الرئيس الثاني والثلاثون
فرانكلين روزفلت من الكونغرس اعلان الحرب
على الياباني اثره هجوم
موافقه الفوريه ثلاثه تعديلات ادخلها
روسفلت على الصياغه ليبدا كلامه باليوم
الذي سيعيش في العار
50 عاما بعدها خطاب نصر ادلى به الرئيس
جورج بوش الاب في السابعه والعشرين من
فبراير
1991 اعلن خلاله تحرير الكويت اثرى عمليه
خاطفه اجبلت القوات العراقيه على الانسحاب
بالقوه من الاراضي الكويتيه بعد استنفاذ
جهود اقناع صدام حسين بالخروج الطوعيه
[تصفيق]
ا لكنه ايد عام 95 ما عرف بسياسه الرفع
والضربه في ما يخص حرب البوسنه متحدثا
بنبره غاضبه ممزوجته
سبتمبر عام 2001 حرب على الارهاب كما
سماها الرئيس الاسبق جورج بوش فصولها في
استمرار
ماشي شويه
او مقصوده كما حصل مع الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب حين مزقت رئيسه مجلس النواب
نانسي
هذه ساعه من التغطيه انتهت ولكنها مستمره
على شاشه العربيه واعود القاكم على راس
ساعه في موجزا لاهم الانباء للاخبار
العالميه الاخرى وسهايد شراير معه الساعه
المقبله من التغطيه فارجو ان تكون معه الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]